hello believe nation I am a Tony Robbins
fan and I've learned a lot from his
teachings and so I thought I'd start a
new series I would test it out once a
month called best of Tony where I would
take a video that's made of the impact
on me that I've learned something from
and share it with you and hopefully
you'll learn as well commit so today
we're going to learn how to reprogram
your mind ain't addiction
hope you enjoy who here is absolutely
totally completely addicted to be that
you can swallow two or three of them
right now
you're so you I mean nothing can stop
you from being so that's how much you
want it 800 addiction Ibiza if you have
that addiction sentence I can see all
right oh then how about I'm gonna film
it right here come on down there give a
hand come on down
[Applause]
first point is you've got to recognize
where you are currently about the task
at hand whether it's running whether
it's teens or anything so you're going
to assign a numeric value to your
experience you can say on a scale from
minus ten
to what plus ten where are you so we'll
say to you on a scale bill from minus 10
to +10 where are you around eating beads
plus fast and it just plus spinners
above plus 10 plus 12 plus well it's not
about accurate yeah plus well okay so
then most people never decided dance the
level of quality pleasure joy excitement
or even pain it's a committed to
experiencing to a given task in advance
so the second step is the conscious to
describe what feelings you want to
experience while doing a particular
activity the third step is aside and
quantify say I'm going to give it this
quality I'm going to make it level 10
experience 9 whatever the fourth step to
the right here is you're going to ask
yourself the question what conditions
must I create inside myself or the
environment or to experience this at
level quality at level whatever okay
we're going to focus on appreciate we
need to do with the task in order to
change what I feel about what we'll do
here with Bill is we will ask him where
he is and we'll get him to move things
for us and tell us what do you have to
do to change it on the scale so bill if
you imagine this is our scale from minus
10 the plus 12 up to add two more
different bill okay to plus 12 what I'm
going to do then I put it beats in front
of him and he'll describe for us a
little bit what are some of the
qualities that he needs so bill here is
a pizza sausage pizza
well first off I don't need a sausage
apparently you need sausage or pepperoni
the cheese and other aspects of pizza
cheese pizza hoagie normal desire for
people they only can only attend it's
only attended now they're selling warm
not really warm
well management warm then can't imagine
it getting warmer it measures kinnexa
mushrooms on it ok imagine some
mushrooms on ebay 12:12 imagine the
mushrooms on it warm sun dried tomatoes
some dried tomatoes dried tomatoes
mushrooms cheese melted cheese with
dripping with jeans dripping with cheesy
what kind of cheese extra cheese what's
your level desire that level now my 15
about 15 okay so extra cheese does that
help him get in that state so let's
write down what does he do to get it
higher write it down your little sheet
here they get even higher what do they
do he adds in his mind that it's really
hot he has in his mind that it's got
mushrooms and against the 15 he puts on
extra what but your face would even says
it look at stake and sun-dried tomato
thank you now think about this pizza now
and I want you to take the speeds if you
would and put it down if you would to
level 8 go ahead hold it with the other
hand level 8 tell me what do you got to
do to make it level 8
plus a it's not really it would be warm
to be warm and maybe it's just cheese
feet sir oh wait I think the time so I
give you the wrong one to move down
there we go if it wasn't really warm it
was just slightly above room temperature
maybe being slightly above room
temperature which is about what that one
is okay it's out today bring it down to
a three it have pepperoni sausage on it
okay no both of them it looked more
attractive when he got more to your face
I just want to drop it okay that's fine
no problem so make it a three and it's
got sausage on it because you don't need
sausage or pepperoni because after all
you're one of those guys that has a
pizza in a light beer I'll take care
either
okay time period do you have a soft
drink diet coke before the seminar
before I understand I'm not on your case
I'm your buddy
but isn't it we all goes let him give me
a big extra cheese pizza and a light
coke
okay so sausage make it a zero
well you should be noticing as much as
what he says do you see the change in
his head you see a change in his
breathing her facial expressions within
the same state yes or no it's even close
where is it now zero to ten there zero
so zero that's been sitting out for now
make it minus three pepperoni and
sausage has been sitting out for now and
the grease is coming out of me
the greens is coming out of me can you
picture that
okay Athena yeah yeah and what if it was
a cheese pizza but it's still minus
three it had also mushrooms on it and it
also had extra cheese but it's still
minus three and I even had tomatoes
sun-dried tomatoes but it's minus three
how do you do that it's been seeing out
for a while
however a couple hours how do you know
when you look at it's kind of glazed
over
I guess the sugars come out from the
cheese on top and kind of placed over
maybe hard getting hard the sugar is
glazed over on top anything else that
makes it -3 well yet okay make it a
minus seven
I can smell the meat kind of rotting a
little bit no the room smell the meat
rotting a little bit where is it down
9:7 the -7 bring it down to minus 9 but
it has no meat that -9 it has mushrooms
and has extra cheese and that sun-dried
tomatoes and it's minus 9
I'm fighting the urge because I'd be
smelling the rancid smell of cheese in
the stomach okay go ahead and do that
well I'm going to throw a paper that me
I wouldn't get that urge you give it the
urge but I will let you throw up almost
when you're at minus 9
you won't do up to me which it - 11 we
won't take it up on which will be real
close
tell us where you are you know - 28 - a
ticket to - 9
what are you focusing on take it to - 9
the smell smell of what cheese Rhett
rotting cheese rotting rancid cheese can
you see what it looks like - am smell it
I continue to look at it can you look at
go ahead look at it while you say that
look at sing pizza let's go just look at
a big pizza tell me when you're in - 9
imagine mushrooms extra cheese mushrooms
extra cheese pizza
that's it mushrooms extra cheese pizzas
that's it mushrooms extra cheese pizza
Rory right now is Caleb 0/10 mushrooms
extra cheese pizzas smelling the rancid
smell look at the piece that when you
think about also see it and smell it
that's it hang on hang on hang on
absent evident mushroom extra cheese
smell it smell the rancid smell that's
it Nelda rancid smell that's it smell it
no there to smell the cheese you can
call us that's it smell be extra cheese
that's a smell it extra cheese
I like some extra ransie cheese whereas
Yonatan like minus 10 right now our side
- why - echo go to - Levin don't go to -
Levin okay
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that looked like a fun and hopefully
valuable tool so thank you guys so much
for watching I'd love to know what do
you think did you like this video you
learn something from my do you want to
see more in the best of Tony new series
or is this a one-off and done number one
is to do it again let me know leave it
down the count's below i'm really
looking forward to hearing your comments
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon